(dramatic, energetic music)
- I know a ton of you are not familiar
with my Monday-to-Monday playlist
that I update every Monday
with Mike Boyd on my Spotify.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Monday and Monday.
That's what's up.
("So Up" by Euro Gotit)
- Monday to Monday, oops, this is me.
I gotta go, see ya, bye.
Okay, everyone out.
(peaceful music)
I want this whole thing,
don't cut it 'cause you'll
lose too much context.
For titling Instagram, and try your best,
I would say the only anecdote
I know is perspective.
Let's play with that, okay?
Yeah, what is it, 28-26-24-20?
Hello friend or family,
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk,
making this video for a
small select group of people
that John, Nate, and I are
going to be reaching out to
here in the month of August and September
to get part of our new wine project.
(feedback test pattern plays)
("Win the Day" by Feeki)
You can't figure it out?
- There's just a lot of
already committed stuff,
like a 4-D's on the 13th, here.
- How many are sold?
- Four sold, two comped.
- Good. Love you for answering so quickly.
("Win the Day by Feeki")